[Music]
hi andrew welcome to the ramsay show
hey how are you guys doing better than i
deserve what's up
all right so
um i have about hundred dollars in
credit card debt i'm cutting it down not
using that credit card anymore
but my question is i have sixteen
hundred and ninety four dollars in
interest-free
credit card debt it's interest-free for
33 more months it's equipment for
my music stuff i'm a musician and i do
stuff like that so
i was just wondering what should i
attack first
uh what should i do with that
interest-free debt should i just pay the
payments till it's done or just pay it
off
okay
well so you have 1600 in debt and you
have how much other debt
uh that's that's the only date i have
you only have sixteen hundred dollars in
debt that's your all your that's that's
that's in the interest free yeah no i'm
saying period period any kind of debt
you have a student loan card debt
other credit cards no student loans new
car debt so i get a paid off car
so the total with the interest rate and
the one with interest i have about three
thousand dollars in that okay
all right and and your household income
is what
uh i make about sixteen hundred or
sixteen thousand a year
okay with that that's including music
stuff and my part-time job as well
i'm a full-time student so oh okay
there's that okay because i was getting
ready to say your job sucks okay
um a full-time job making 16k puts you
at the poverty level so we don't want to
call that a career track okay
uh so we need to so what are you going
to do when are you getting out of school
what's your plan
i've got about two years left in school
i'm still at home so i don't have any
rent
um i don't have a mortgage or anything
like that
after that um
what are you studying graduating
uh marketing good okay so i want to go
into sales so you're a college student
that lives at home with three thousand
dollars in debt
and how how is school paid for
my father pays for that very nice okay
are you running up are you buying music
equipment are you playing shows on the
weekend trying to make it or is it just
a hobby
no yeah i mean that was that's the dream
but i also want a backup plan because i
don't want to you know go move up to
nashville and uh
you know
not make it and be stuck i'd be stuck at
that point yeah how do you get the next
country music star's attention in
nashville
uh waiter yeah so um
uh
all right
okay
num
number one you got a good overall plan
number two if you're making sixteen
hundred dollars
or seventeen thousand dollars a year you
should pay this debt off with no way out
of pocket expenses to mount anything
very very quickly would you agree with
me that you're gonna be done with the
entire amount of debt within three to
six months is that doable it is isn't it
yeah yeah i don't think so okay and so
really the interest rate doesn't matter
because you're gonna be done in three to
six months now what we teach to answer
your question technically andrew is to
list your debts smallest to largest
and uh sounds like they're about the
same size
regardless of interest rate pay minimum
payments on
everything but your smallest debt attack
the smallest debt first regardless of
interest rate so the fact that it's a
zero percent interest does not impress
me does not change the order in which i
pay it off i would pay off the smallest
one first regardless of the interest
rate because i want you to have the
emotional advantage of traction
seeing that you're starting to win
rather than living off of these credit
cards you're putting them under your
heel and grinding them
and being done with them and that's the
big thing but it sounds like these are
very similar
i mean if they're both sixteen seventeen
hundred dollars each
then then you got three thousand dollars
total then you know just uh you can put
whichever one you want first but be done
with the whole thing in six months but
let's just say you had ten different
debts and one of them was a thousand one
almost ten thousand uh
but the the the one thousand was
interest free would i still put it first
yes i would because i want you to get
the traction the advantage of this
psychological income of winning it's
called hope and it causes people to
continue to move through this and that's
how
we at ramsey have gotten more people out
of debt than probably any other
organization on the planet
at least currently operating and andrew
let me let me speak to you here
there is a
gibson flying v
electric guitar
that i've been eyeballing for like six
months
and i can afford it but my wife and i
have made some goals and some plans and
so i'm holding off i'm holding off and
now instagram listens to me and they
just send me these pictures of the
guitar and another one and another one
you're going to have to not buy music
equipment for a season just stop
you think you need a new thing for this
and a new you gotta have that you don't
need it there's no end to it there's it
just will continue to consume you and
i'm in the middle of
that myself any people that play music
have an addictive problem for their
instruments
music people car people gun people like
it just happen so
you got to stop buying equipment say i'm
not going to buy another thing piece of
gear for another year and then i'm going
to get out of debt wait if i need
another gun that's different that's
that's right that's right
don't get leave the cars alone right my
car is alone yeah no it's the same thing
you get you get you get to where
and the truth is there's almost nothing
in america that we buy that qualifies as
a need
very few almost everything we buy
qualifies as a want
very few i mean we pretty much are all
over fed and have too many clothes
and we pretty much all have a place to
sleep so food shelter clothing
transportation we got it covered you
know i mean it's not an issue
and so that that's not the problem in
america now there's nothing wrong with
spending money on once
but we just tell folks to be really
careful and be emotionally mature enough
to say
that is a want right
and once
for sure you pay cash for it and for
sure they've got to go in line with your
overall goal
yep
yeah yeah so one of the
issues that rachel cruz talks about a
lot and i do too as well we're talking
about teaching kids about money is
teaching them
contentment
to learn to sit in what you have and
being good with it um and you know that
how far you could go in the music
business with the music equipment you
already have is amazing yep that's right
and without ever buying another thing
right uh it's amazing
and uh how
you know i if i could just get that if i
could just get that that's a
discontentment the advertisers and the
marketers job is to create psychological
dissonance
discomfort
in you so that you feel i will be
comfortable when i'll be satiated when
i get that next thing and and you know
that that's the driving force of the
most marketed to advertised to culture
in the history of mankind
in the history of the human race and you
live right square in the middle of it
and so do i
we see four to eight thousand
advertisements a day
there are advertisements in the bathroom
for god's sakes on the front and the
back of the door they're everywhere
ridiculous you know and so
you're not getting away from it and so
what you have to learn is the spiritual
and emotional
psychological discipline
to say no no it's a complete sentence